- So, Neil, what is the
coolest new science thing
you've learned to tell me?
- I've learned cool
science things every day.
And sometimes I have to be
(laughing) reminded of them.
Maybe I knew them long ago.
- Yeah.
- Like we all knew that we have very,
a high common DNA with
chimpanzees, like 99% identical.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you say, okay,
I get that,
but do you know we also have
50% common DNA with a banana?
(audience laughs)
- I do love bananas.
- Okay?
- My son, all he eats is bananas.
- [Neil] There you go.
And I got one other for ya, you ready?
If you look at the Tree of Life,
the common ancestors
between humans and mushrooms
split after--
- What kind of mushrooms?
(all laughing)
- After the common ancestor
between our common
ancestor and green plants,
which means we and mushrooms
are more genetically connected
than either of us are to green plants.
- What?
- I know.
- We are like fungus sometimes.
- [Neil] We are a fungus among us, yeah.
- And--
- [Lucy] Interesting.
- And some people have whole
relationships with mushrooms.
(audience laughs)
- You know?
- Yes.
- You know what?
- That's what I'm sayin'.
- I know those people.
- [Lucy] Yes.
(Neil laughs)
- And I'm like, be around people you love
and that love you.
- So, these are new facts.
I'm more likely to learn
a new fact in a science
that's not my specialty.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, but I love learning.
- [Kelly] Me too.
If it's out of my specialty with science,
I'm just totally lost.
(all laughing)